lors de ta recherche tu dois formuler au
minimum une hypothèse une hypothèse
c'est en fait une réponse provisoire à
ta question de départ c'est donc une
affirmation pour être valide ton
hypothèse doit être falsifiable ce qui
signifie qu'elle peut être contredite
par l'observation en fait on peut très
bien formuler des hypothèses qui seront
toujours vrai et donc qui ne peuvent pas
être démentis par exemple si je dis que
ce sont les enfants qui sont victimes de
violences infantile forcément ça sera
toujours vrai et ce ne sont donc pas de
bonnes hypothèses un des éléments
importants pour assurer la
falsifiabilité de tes hypothèses va être
d'utiliser des termes précis parce que
des termes trop généraux empêchent
justement leur vérification on prend
pour hypothèse que les gens sont
influencés dans leur vie ça sera
généralement assez vrai mais on ne sait
pas qui sont les gens quels sont les
éléments qui influencent et surtout
qu'est-ce qui dans leur vie est
influencé et donc il faudrait être
beaucoup plus précis sur tous ces termes
pour pouvoir avoir une hypothèse
falsifiable
[Musique]